avion de prestige concorde est devenu de
plus en plus coûteux avec les hausses
continuelles de carburant transportant
110 passagers trois fois moins qu airbus
ils consomment quatre fois plus de
carburant par passager
c'est le prix de la vitesse disent ses
partisans argument commercial qui aurait
dû séduire les passagers hors concorde
n'est remplie qu'à 57 % en dessous du
seuil de rentabilité la direction d'air
france ne voulant pas supporter seuls le
déficit avait obtenu de l'état qu'il en
prenne à sa charge les trois quarts dans
le nouveau contrat signé aujourd'hui
c'est 95% du déficit qui sera payé par
l'état c'est-à-dire les contribuables
pour que concorde puisse voler il en
coûtera donc cette année 20 francs à
chaque français les contribuables
paieront encore plus et les passagers
encore moins 90 mille passagers
seulement dont plus de la moitié
d'américains
alors qu'à peine un français sur 20
prend l'avion on a de quoi donner des
arguments à ceux qui demandent soit que
les passagers paient réellement le prix
du billet soit que l'état mais de
concorde au musée